welcome to the program we begin in
Belarus where the Wagner mercenary Chief
yevgeny pagosian has confirmed to be
living in Exile he traveled there on
Tuesday after leading an armed Rebellion
against Russia days earlier fellow
Russian President Alexander lukashenko
brokered the deal that allowed pagosian
to move to Belarus and end the brief
Mutiny by Wagner Fighters while Vladimir
Putin called Wagner's actions treasonous
Russia's FSB security service has
dropped criminal charges against
pregosian's fighters let's get the
latest now from Yulia shapovalova who's
live for us in Moscow hello there Yulia
it's now Wednesday morning in Moscow
several days after that short-lived
Mutiny what's the mood like across
Russia
that's right as we earlier heard from
Bella Russian President Alexander
lukashenka evgeny preggersian head of
the Wagner group is in Belarus he was
allowed to flee there and scathed by the
Russian authorities uh early legoshenko
was very outspoken about his
negotiations with progression to put an
end to the Wagner Rebellion last weekend
now we hear questions about what is
going to happen to pregosian's Empire in
Saint Petersburg in particular he's
loved his numerous media sources the
Wagner Center restaurants and other
assets and there is also a school for
drone pilots and businesses related to
catering and food delivery to schools
and hospitals as well as real estate
business so journalists had a chance to
speak to some of the management of all
those businesses and seems like
everything works as usual and all
remains in place but people are a bit
worried there and waiting for further
instructions while military bloggers in
their telegram channels here rise at the
Wagner armed Rebellion triggered
large-scale inspections and even purges
in the high ranks of the Russian Armed
Forces testing them for loyalty and
there are reports that representatives
of the FSB have been figuring out who
did not resist Wagner Fighters enough
among the leadership of a military
command of the military command and unit
commanders there apart from that Moscow
Russia lived their normal daily life but
it will be interesting to follow how the
day progresses and all developments it
will bring yes certainly that Fallout
continues Yulia what does progosian's
exile mean for the future of Wagner And
also the other leaders within the group
well it's quite interesting we've heard
that according to the uh Saudi TV
channel Al Hadas the Russian military
police detanged the head of a Wagner
branch in southern Syria as well as
three high-ranking commanders of the
Wagner group at the Russian Maine Air
Base in Syria and there were also police
raids on Wagner in other Syrian cities
but later a message appeared on a
telegram channel of Dmitry udkin who is
associated with the leadership of the
vagina saying that the information was
not true the authorities of Russia and
Syria did not comment on the information
either and also some sources reported
that the authorities of the Central
African Republic were alarmed about the
events in Russia and there were
concerned that some Wagner units might
leave the Republic but we do not see any
reports that they have actually okay
Plenty happening there thanks so much